do you ever find yourself talking to
your spouse or a friend about a camera
you want to buy or a car you want to buy
or specific thing you want to buy next
you know for the next 24 hours all you
see is all these ads you never searched
it you never did anything are they
watching are they listening to you
what's your data worth do you know what
percentage of Americans actually know
anything about how marketing companies
track your data my data you know what
the number is less than 3% know exactly
they did a sample of 2,000 Americans
asking 17 questions to see how many of
these questions they would get right
this is the results 77% got anywhere
between 0 to9 right that's a failing
grade 15% got 10 to 11 right 6% 12 to 13
only 1% got 14 to 15 right .3% got 16
right perfect score was pretty much
impossible out there why most people
don't know how this industry work the
whole industry global data broker like
meaning if you're selling other people's
information you know how big that was in
2022 268 billion and estimated to be
$365 billion in 2029 by the way most
people don't even know how this industry
Works we're going to talk about that
today if you get value out of this video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel let me kind of share with you
what world economic Forum said in 2011
they said it was theorized that personal
data will become a new asset class and
will become one of the most valuable
resources on the planet so valuable that
68% of businesses worldwide in 2021 were
buying third party data from data
Brokers and by the way if you want to
see which countries were leading the way
here's what it looks like at the top us
73% EU not including UK was 71% non-eu
Europe 69% Canada 59 Asia 56 Latin
America 51 Middle East 48 UK 43 and you
got the rest of them but the US very
interested in what you and I do very
very interested and just to kind of give
you a vision ual what this really means
in 2021 it was estimated that data
Brokers held information about customers
that would fill you know how many filing
cabinets ready 16 trillion filing
cabinets with all the data they gather
with you and I by the way do you know
how much information they have on you
like what different data points you
ready is it like 50 you think 100 maybe
200 that's crazy 200 right you ready
according to World privacy Forum the
average data broker has information on
approximately 1,500 data points for
every consumer they probably know one
girl you kiss that no one knows about
they have it in here they probably got
it here when they're selling that
information a study done by FTC found
that one data broker segment alone held
information on 1.4 billion consumer
transactions and over 700 billion raw
data elements to put it in perspective
it's about 90 times the number of tweets
sent globally in a year same May same
Pat how's this even allowed it's because
we give them permission how do we give
them permission have you seen the terms
of service of different companies by the
way do you want to take a while guess
which one of these big online companies
I don't know Amazon on Facebook
Instagram Twitter Microsoft Apple which
one you think has the longest terms of
service that you and I sign I'm going to
break it down for you here in a minute
but there is no federal law in the US
that regulates the data broker industry
we give them permission and here's what
it looks like terms of service take a
look at this year which one's the
longest when you look at it here they
got Facebook Instagram Spotify Twitter
LinkedIn YouTube Apple Amazon Tik Tok
Netflix Microsoft we got a bunch of them
right the shortest ones are actually
instag
and Netflix Instagram is 2451 total W
count Netflix is 2628 but you know who
the longest one is Microsoft you know
where Microsoft at
15,20 that's terms of service
15,20 terms of service when's the last
time you read all the terms of service
when's the last time we read them do we
go through them you know how long will
would take if we went through all of
these that's what happens when we just
say agree they get all our data by the
way just a bonus for you just to put
that in perspective you know the
Microsoft terms of service the amount of
words that it has the book Art of War by
sunu is only 12,35 words that means
Microsoft's terms of service is bigger
than you reading The Art of War by sunu
pretty wild by the way another thing to
to consider here when it comes down to
data you ever see all these websites
that at the bottom you're like I want to
really read this article accept all
cookies and what do we do accept all
cookies that's also data they're getting
you know what percentage of website have
cookies
42.4% of websites globally use cookies
65% of survey conducted by deloid
respondent Express profound concerns
regarding the excessive use of cookies
and its potential impact on their
personal data so this industry is such a
big industry do you know how many
companies in America just focus on
selling data what do you think it is
like how many real estate companies are
out there how many insurance companies
are out there how many companies you
think in America just focus on selling
data you ready I think it's 220 580 how
about 1100 that's crazy try 4,000 4,000
companies that specialize in selling
your data and by the way you know they
say in 2019 45% of your information that
they sold was marketing and advertising
data brokerage market demand but the
question is what do they do with the
other 55% what's the information being
sold no one knows there's a lot of
people speculating but no one knows a
Pew research surveyed revealed that 91%
of adults agree or strongly agree that
consumers have lost control over their
personal data and by the way which
industry you think is the fastest
growing in data brokerage what industry
do you think just take a wild guess by
2022 the health and Pharma industry
anyone surprised is projected to have
the fastest growth in data and brokerage
services and by the way whether you're
in the military or previous or you have
friends and family that are in it this
is very interesting report from duke
Sanford School of Public Policy
companies are gathering inferring
aggregating and then selling licensing
and sharing data on Americans as well as
providing technological Services based
on that data the Duke report also said
data Brokers are selling data on US
military personnel the data brokerage
ecosystem poses R to National Security
by compiling large large detailed
databases on military personnel and
subsequently selling that data on the
open market here's what they're
Gathering ready I'll go through it
fairly quickly detailed informational
service members government records
medical conditions medical records
financial situation and credit scores
political affiliation religious identity
gender and sexuality address and contact
information children and family surveys
Healthcare directories active military
occupational data on-based housing
information Department of Veteran
Affairs mortgage data Hobbies such as
gambling or International travel
cap they want to know whether you gamble
or not if you're in the military that's
pretty wild detail geolocation data that
can be used to identify military
locations and movements let me get this
straight we're selling the data to tell
whoever wants to buy it where our
military personnel is I wonder who would
want to buy that I mean I can't think of
any countries definitely China wouldn't
be interested I know Iran wouldn't be
interested Russia wouldn't be interested
in things like this they don't want to
know where our military LR not at all
they're trying to mind their own
business right utility and new phone
connection records quote forms order
forms sweep stake forms partnership with
list providers commissaries on Military
approved buyers partnership with over
900 sources including data gathered from
public records social media accounts
online purchase records online purchase
records online purchase records public
tax documents public tax document
doesn't that have your social on it
credit reports national Clearing House
Records phone email poster surveys call
center compilation live feed voter data
data from commercial resources medical
records government records nonprofits
serving military and Veteran causes
public records all of this stuff they
are selling that data and by the way
what do you think your data is worth if
you're in a military watching this run
saying I'm an ABC I'm a army green beret
I'm a sergeant I'm an officer I'm a
colonel I'm a onear general you know
what they're selling this per military
service member what do you think it is
200 bucks 100 bucks you're like it's got
to be worth more than that what if I
told you 22 that's what they're selling
it you may buy it you're watching say I
I would want to buy it for my company
right they're selling it for only 22
cents a pot and by the way I I can't
give you so many other weird sto I want
to give you a couple random stories FYI
every year you know like your
information gets stolen do you know how
many children's information gets stolen
on a yearly basis children's identity
915,000 by the way did you hear the
story about the mother that stole her
daughter's identity to go become a high
schooler so she can have pom pons and be
a cheerleader and she gets caught and
goes to jail of course she's got issues
33 years old to do this and she steals
her daughter's information by the way
luckily this is the mom doing it to the
daughter imagine if the stranger doing
it to somebody else this is the story of
Wendy Brown who stole her daughter's
information Jamie that's mom daughter
915,000 per year but let me give you
another one I'm going to take you back
to a story in 2004 back in the days
people have been stealing information
for a long time in 2004 Facebook I think
came out in 04 or give or take that's
like when these guys come out we're not
get used on social regularly this guy
named Philip Cummings is working at this
company he's got a regular desk job at
teledata Communications in Long Island
New York and he helped people run
routine credit checks when he left his
job he packed up his belonging along
with the confidential information that
belonged to
33,000 people him and his accomplice end
up selling this thing to other people
that were interested you know how much
to find was at the end the US Department
of Justice estimated they made somewhere
between 50 to1 million data has been
important for a very very long time back
in the days people did it this way today
it's a lot easier cuz you use all these
apps regularly and you always accepting
cookies and you always accepting terms
of service you're not sitting there for
10 hours reading all these terms of
service so guess what we're essentially
giving them the permission to use all
our data and Military informations being
sld for 22 cents on a dollar so so let
me give you an idea with all this data
stuff where I'm not concerned and where
I am concerned so for example if you're
using the data to retarget and sell me a
product that I showed a little bit of
interest in cool I get it it's on me to
say yes or no now some people are like
but that's not that's not cool they're
targeting and all this stop it you know
if you want to go to a Market
Supermarket go to Ralphs go to Kroger's
where do you think they have their milk
right in the front the number one
product people buy when they go to a
market is what milk they put that
all the way in the back because they
want us to do what walk all the way to
the back and like I'm only going to buy
milk and then you're like Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam you went to buy milk for
five bucks you end up Le at $88 they use
it you fell for it I fell for it all the
time it's normal Costco does it where do
they put all the stuff that we have to
buy meat is where 17 miles all the way
down you got to walk up and then you got
another 45 minutes of stuff you're going
to pick up next thing you got a case of
mustard as if you're going to start a
side business of selling mustard why do
you need 17 years of supply of mustard
well we picked it you know what I'm
going to save some money as if you're
going to use mustard all that in a month
so I don't mind if they're retargeting
to sell me new product or the same
product I'm interested I'm okay with
that what I am concerned about is the
movie Minority Report if you remember it
which was future Behavior what you can
future crimes you can commit there's
this show on HBO called Westworld where
they have this AI system that based on
this AI you do they hire you do they not
hire you are you good to come on board
what if they do this and what if they do
that and you know you're not a good
person to hire because your behavior in
the future is going to be that's the
stuff that gets a little bit interesting
where can people get arrested on a
future crime can people get get held
back for certain things you know China's
already using the social credit system
to track what you can get what you can't
get voting this is where you're going to
be at and they put you in a box that's
the part that's a little fishy to me I
have no problem with capitalists trying
to put their product in front of me to
buy it over and over again I'm okay with
that I'm a big boy if I buy it great if
I don't buy it I have to be able to
control it it's the other things that
I'm a little bit concerned about so I'll
give you a couple things as a solution
while you're going through this cuz I
know some of you guys that are paranoid
people you're freaking out right now
like oh my God what do I do do take all
the apps down delete every app you got
get off of everything right so I'm not
telling you that but you have to know
it's a different world we're living in
it's better to be aware here's a few
things on how to protect your personal
data freezing your credit is one way to
do it being alert for scams there's a
lot of different apps you can use to
give you alerts on somebody's using the
things that they're that they're using I
get so many alerts when somebody buy
like how'd you know cuz I got alerts
that I know who's buying and who's using
what practicing good password hygiene
protecting your devices locking up your
stuff a sound data security plan is
build on five key principles is what FTC
tells you number one take stock know
what personal information you have in
your files and on your computers number
two scale down keep only what you need
for your business number three lock it
protect the information that you keep
number four pitch it properly dispose of
what you no longer need last but not
least plan ahead create a plan to
respond to security incidents so if you
got value out of this video give it a
thumbs up subscribe to the channel by
the way this is probably an episode you
may want to watch with your spouse Mom
Dad grandparents it's probably something
everybody needs to watch a Le more about
it but I interview somebody a few years
ago guy named Matthew Cox you probably
seen him on TV this was FBI's Most
Wanted guy in the area of loopholes in
the system he actually breaks down how
he would defraud Banks using other
people's CR absolutely wild what he did
if you want to learn exactly how to use
it you may as well learn it from
somebody that did it for many years and
made millions of dollars toing US if
you've never watch us before click here
to watch it aside from that have a good
day everybody take care bye-bye
bye-bye
a